okay cool next question who benefits the
most from Marriage men or women
what do you think
women women why'd you say that
because it depends actually depends on
the dynamic of the the marriage like if
she's like a stay-at-home wife
then
and he's like doing the most and he's
You Know Rich and whatever
she just does you know the standard
stuff that women do you know cooking
cleaning or whatever he'll come home
bring the cheap all of that stuff she's
and then if she like not saying that
there's some girls I'll do it but you
know if you divorce them you're taking
half you know he might have worked
harder for it but you can still take it
okay what about you what do you think
about it no one no one
exactly
that's sad bro oh why'd you say no one
benefits how do you think that marriage
is difficult it's a lot of time work
energy and so I don't see like a man or
a woman who's gonna like hope for women
because or men I think it's really hard
for both to be committed to be there to
be a good parent to you know be dealing
with your personal life your do you
think it might be harder for one party
harder it's hard for both but do you
think it may be harder for a woman or
harder for a man I think it's equally
for both hard for both because the
responsibility is for both so in a
marriage in a different ways let's say
demands the provider but he is also
needs to be in a work where he hates his
boss but he needs to be there so
different kind of challenge but
difficult for both for sure
okay so
um in relationship earlier I asked you
there's always a method there's a method
to my madness in it while I ask the
questions the way I ask them because
earlier I asked you who do you think is
easier to please in a relationship and
you said man
yes so if that's true and we've agreed
to that yes you've already agreed to
that yeah yeah so in a marriage which is
a relationship
why is it all of a sudden 50 50.
because I think like uh the
responsibility when you have a family is
not you're talking about it in a
relationship marriage marriage in a
marriage I think is is 50 50 if someone
gets sick the other needs to take care
so let's say is difficult for both I
don't see like for women or from America
who takes more Advantage because I don't
think but don't you see how that kind of
contradicts what you agreed to earlier
but you said differently if it's easier
to please a man in a relationship let's
say man it's very simple women can do 10
tasks at the same time but men just
can't do one so man is super simple how
does that mean how does that change
anything women can be driving doing
their makeup be on the phone at the same
time you're talking about men and women
pleasing each other you're talking about
women can multitask what are you talking
about no because you were telling me
earlier about us if it's easier to
please a man and a woman would never be
easy to please because in her mind would
be thousand things going on with you and
never guess what is there okay so if we
go with what you're saying a man is
easier to please correct and a woman is
harder to please because she's got a
million things going on in her mind plus
hormones and emotions and all of this
stuff so when you get into a marriage
what changes to make it now 50 50. the
commitment it's the responsibility to
keep together it's like half and half I
don't see like for one side it was going
to be better comparing to the other for
me it's equal
sorry
sorry I want to kind of go back back
because you said about structure I feel
like when he was also talking about the
wifey material thing what you listed as
a guy
um
when you said it and I'm I'll take it on
because you're a guy it didn't sound
hard like I'm not trying to like put I
could uh but it just didn't sound that
hard and then for my idea of what like a
guy would have to go through in terms of
a marriage it just sounds like more work
on their end like I don't know if that
makes sense no it makes sense what's
more work for the men are the women for
the men like I feel like the the list of
things that he said about for a wife to
do that and to just be there for them
and do the just simple stuff yeah just
care and do the simple stuff like
cleaning and with that like this is
really simple in my eyes and then he's
going out as you said he could hate his
boss his boss could be bullying him but
because if it's a dynamic of a marriage
where he's the provider the protect and
all that he's gonna have that in his
head and he's gonna like fight and
continue doing this stuff so really and
truly I I don't want to be mean but I
kind of do disagree with what she's
saying that if he was going by
Distraction that I just wanted to say
that but yeah what do you think about
what she just said
different opinions yeah it's just
different opinions
I mean but like
you haven't really come up with any
logical rebuttal like you're just saying
oh it's just different because
commitment that's what you said really
yes it's really hard for you to be in a
commitment to be with a person it
doesn't matter if you're in a
relationship
a marriage especially which is involve a
lot of
a lot of things like
bureaucracy change our name and it
changed their life just aside so how
does that
sorry sorry but like you're just saying
you're just saying anything you you just
have your weight you have your opinion
and you just want to stick to it
regardless even if you have nothing to
uh you know no evidence or no logic or
nothing to back up what you're saying
just talking at this point like that
that made no sense can I can I ask you a
question what do you think what do you
think a man won out of marriage if you
give me three things
give me three things just three
wow
that's good question because most of the
time they get married because the women
are the one all the time asking and
being like right but if a guy's okay if
a guy's thinking what his wife would do
for him what's one thing she would do
like the first thing that comes to your
head
in a marriage for a man yeah
what did he not get until he was married
in the old days
family
children
Okay no Okay
that's okay that's fine that's one he
does get children out of a marriage what
else
how does how does he get the children
how do they make their children no sex
of course okay so do you think sex is
important to men in a marriage
yes okay what what do women want out of
a marriage
stability okay and would you say that
you get that through long-term
commitment right
so what if I told you one in four
marriages were sexless one in four I
believe so do you who's it harder for
that if we're getting the commitment
from him but they're not getting the sex
from us
wow would that would that change your
point of view a little bit
no no I agree I know like there's a lot
of marriage we there is no sex involved
and it's normal but
that's that's our people they are
different like well I'm my whole point
is that like as the women we in that
deal it's not a fair deal because we get
the protection and provisioning and the
long-term commitment which is what we
want right I mean unless you marry the
guy that you know assuming you don't
marry a guy that's gonna run right but
the men it's like the most important
thing that men want
is to bend the girl over backwards you
know what I mean and so it's like they
don't even they don't even get that out
of it and so it's like it's like the
number one thing that they want we can't
even give them so it almost becomes an
unfair deal because these guys get
married and they're thinking dang I get
this unlimited sex with my wife and then
she's like nah I got the kids I'm good
she's like Nabi
I'm friends with this divorce attorney
and he said it's really common for women
to stop sleeping with their husbands
after they get their children I I
believe that too as many of you know I
was just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible